what would be the greatest job in the
world that you could ever have and think
of anything
anything at all what would you like to
do for eight hours a day
how do you define story and how do you
teach it to students and clients we tell
stories all the time
even as i'm talking to you i'm telling
stories i'm bringing characters in
um
we
we're we're made to tell stories we're
made to we're made to tell stories about
what you know our aunt did that oh my
god she's she's crazy she's out of her
mind you know what she did and so we're
story building constantly just even even
if we don't know it
and
then that's when we go okay so how do we
craft it and then it's just like let's
that's when i talk about character and
plot let's talk about a character
okay what does this character do let's
talk about plot and then um what i i do
this i do a free writing workshop for
the library once a month and so it's one
of my favorite things to do because i
get
nobody i know in there it's just like
all of a sudden i have all these
eyeballs looking at me going teach us
how to write a story
and and sometimes they have a lot of
experience and sometimes it's the first
time they've ever even thought of being
a writer
and
so right away i just talk about
character and plot and
the
what drives me nuts about
there's
monumental
catalog of books out there you know 500
pages how to create a plot into
screenplay 500 pages character work
and throw all those out
there's not it
is the we can't be bogged down by this
intellectual this is how it is in black
blank blank blank blank it is good to
read those books i mean i'm a fan of
joseph campbell i'm a fan of
um
you know i i'm a geek about storytelling
but as far as as far as it's concerned
just start writing and just have a
character
and just give them a goal and then just
get in the way of the goal and just see
what happens
and then what i do is i do free writing
so i'll do a free writing exercise so
i'll just put that i'll have them do a
free write
and then they usually don't know that
there's a second and third part i'll
throw in the plot twist for them and and
then they're and then they they've they
create kind of full-fledged stories
within 30 minutes
and
there's a beauty to that it's it's uh
there's a beauty to
um
having a time limit
and then just going you know what
you all wrote crap everything you wrote
is problematic and awful i can't wait
till you bore me with your story
because what you wrote is you know you
it took you 30 minutes there's people
that write for years to write a good
short story so
let's let's see what happens and
usually they're all very interesting
they're it's
way more interesting than anyone would
ever think and um so that's
that's kind of
how i
wanted you know i want people to just
jump into it
and
write a story in 30 minutes and then
kind of walk away and go
i can do it and this is like yeah you
can but you kind of got to do it every
day
and it's got to be a practice like
anyone could anyone could do yoga
they might you know but you're not going
to go do a handstand on the first day if
you've never done yoga in your life you
got to come and practice every day you
got to you know teach your body so when
you're writing you got to teach your
mind teach your mind that you're coming
to the page you're coming to the page
then your mind starts to go oh crap
we're coming to the page i better come
up with something so
yeah
can you give me an example of let's
suppose what a free writing sort of uh
assignment the in five minutes karen i
need you to
[Music]
and and you you would have me
write something out what would it be so
uh what what i so here's an assignment
that i get that i give is i asked i i
would say karen what what would be the
greatest job in the world that you could
ever have and think of anything
anything at all what would you like to
do for eight hours a day
and then
i would hear what you would like to do
for eight hours a day and i'd be like
great
on this scenario you're going to get
50 million dollars a year to have this
job
but you only have one more you've been
through eight interviews they want you
you have one more interview
so you need
to um
you need to drive to the interview but
when you as you're driving to the
interview
you're gonna get a car accident and
someone's going to cut you off
and so right and i would tell you to
write that
write that scene you got the last
interview for the greatest job in the
world for all the money you could ever
want
but this car cut you off
and that would be the beginning of
that writing exercise
and then
the plot twist yeah everyone write it
out and usually it's just like that you
know that just i'm gonna cool and oh you
know and it's just great they like
really get into it because
as they find something they're
passionate about the character it's
we've created the character the
character has a passion and the
character has a goal
and then
after that that limit i go okay great
now you're now your character's at the
interview
and they find out that the person they
got in the car accident with is the
person that's interviewing them
now how does that play out and
that's when it's just like you know
because they weren't thinking of that
there and so then they they're like oh
how do we
how do we resolve this huge problem now
usually that has been
a very contentious scene is now the
person that they need so
it's a lot of fun and then after that
my big question is that the last
sentence is do they get the job or do
they not get the job
and
usually it's 50 50.
usually people find a way around it
people it's
so that would be that that would be one
of the the one of the one of the lessons
i use a lot to get someone to write and
that would be about 30 minutes so i'd
have them right about 10 minutes just
really dive into the anger of the scene
ten minutes of resolution and then
uh five minutes after that so
excellent
that sounds fun
yeah i know sometimes the beauty of
being in a writing class is just hearing
the other people it's not it's not so
much getting critique on your own
yeah and in that situation there's no
critique at all because
it's just re it's just reading it oh i
see okay so and and for the most part
everyone is laughing at every story
because they're so good
and it's and people get really ten like
i've had people who are like that is the
first time i have ever read
anything i've written in front of
everybody it happens more than not
and um and i'm like were you expecting
that reaction they're like no and i'm
like
you got story to tell so
make a decision you're going to join us
in hell
what is it laugh with the sinners or cry
with the saints um virginia come mom you
know yeah
i don't know why i'm singing i shouldn't
be singing why are you allowing me to do
this no no
but i village i would join in if i knew
it i got to watch mystic pizza i got to
listen to billy joel
if we were to have a tony duchaine
part writing process
to a story what would that be
i don't know why i'm drawing a blank a
pen paper
uh
yeah a pen
paper good cup of coffee
or whatever or whatever drink
um
and uh a desk or even a chair just
somewhere
and um
you know
whether you're disturbed or not
disturbed i think something that
happened with kovid is uh
people said oh it must be great for you
because you can write now like you want
i'm like no no no you don't get it i
have to be irritated right people are
not i need to be in a cafe where people
are talking loud on their cell phones
people are being awful and i have to
tune that out and then i have to write i
have to kind of write in the
in situations where it's kind of
antagonistic where things are coming at
me
and that's when i do my best writing
when i'm at peace i don't do great
writing
yeah yeah no the certain coffee shops
are great um for conflict and for oh and
it has to be boring people are like oh
do you have intelligentsia i'm like oh
no i'm at coffee bean
they're just like why would you go there
and like because it's boring and
corporate oh so you don't want too much
too much happening i don't want it to be
cool oh i see okay yeah yeah i i don't
want it to be hip
okay so no filtered
water and you know
yeah
ravica beans or what you've got to have
more just i mean my coffee bean has
great coffee so yeah you just want
something where it's not there's not
hipsters coming in all the time well
yeah it's it i just i don't want the
whole place to be a fashion show
oh okay yeah you know
but it's a group you know
hipsters or not i mean people look at me
and people look at me and sometimes oh
great there's a hipster here i get it
well sometimes what's greater are old
diners i know they're hard to find where
there's someone that i'll be right with
you and it's like they're going to serve
it from one of those ancient coffee pots
and that's great because there's so many
characters in a place like that and it's
real quiet and there's just
everyone you know like each person has a
fascinating story like what they're
doing and
yeah but there's not that many places
like that anymore yeah they've been
replaced
you